let's finish out with one last story I
found on the pages of social media this
is what I'm
liking all right as we've talked about
much of this hour it can be difficult
for people in the trans and non-gender
conforming Community to find safe spaces
to just kick back and be themselves that
is one reason a Brooklyn athlete decided
to open outbox a boxing gym designed as
an inclusive place for anyone and
everyone looking for a good workout but
particularly those who identify as lgbtq
Plus we have him on the line right now
watching on NBC4 New York let's welcome
Max
everybody hi Kelly what's up
Max oh my God I love all the colorful
gloves I'm so into it Kelly we're a gay
gym here come on all right I love it I
love it so explain the gym to everyone
all right well we're a trans owned
boxing gym that centers the lgbtq plus
Community particularly our trans and
non-binary members our gym is completely
non-gendered everything from from your
your first experience at the front desk
the bathrooms locker rooms the language
our instructors use we take uh gender
out of everything um I think that is a
huge part that keeps people out of the
gym especially trans folks and all of
our trainers are queer which I'm proud
to say and um we are we've become way
more than just a gym we've become a
community space we've had drag shows
we've had parties we've had karaoke
nights blasting since you've been gone
yes um we a special SP here so well okay
so this idea came from personal
experience right it did yes I was a
competitive boxer and um I was about to
go pro and the only problem is that I
was in the female Division and I knew my
whole life I was trans I just picked
boxing over my happiness for almost 30
years of my life um after the pandemic
happened like many many trans people
honestly I was like now is the time um
everything's closed and I decided um
that I need to I need to do something
for myself and I transitioned and that's
when I realized Wow Gyms and sports are
really uncomfortable spaces and they
don't want us here um so uh during the
pandemic when everything was closed I
decided to start um hosting lgbtq plus
boxing classes in the park and week
after week after week they were they
were not only selling out that there was
people coming out of the woodwork like
more people um week after week so I was
like I think there's I think there's a
huge need for this and that's when
outbox was born we opened up a a brick
and mortar Gym in Brooklyn and we've
been going ever since well
congratulations it's incredible what you
did for yourself and what you're doing
for others thank you so much Max I'm
liking your post right now right oh
thank and that's not all our season long
partner pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show want to
honor truly Unstoppable people just like
you so they're going to be rting check
for $1,000 how's that
sound that's awesome I did not know that
absolutely have a good one man thank you
to all our guests this hour Patricia
Clarkson Trace L Le Cox Jeff Harley and
Cara y'all have a great day and if it's
not try to change
[Music]
it
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home